[Musique]
je viens très régulièrement sur sur ce
site tout simplement parce que je suis
je propose des hébergements insolites et
dans mon activité j'ai besoin donc de
matériel et je suis toujours dans la
récupération la deuxième main et dans
une économie économie circulaire et
éco-responsable
[Musique]
ce qui me dérangeait en tant que
technicien ici c'est que on voyait des
choses qui étaient valables et qui
étaient jetées de télévision qui
arrivait et qui était jeté à
l'enfouissement et ça c'était plus
possible
c'est devenu très cher donc le fait de
trouver des choses gratuites ici et puis
pouvoir faire des cadeaux enfin voilà ça
permet de gâter les gens les enfants
[Musique]